sur ce plateau inda bigot gilet jaune
organisatrice de manifestations
bonjour india à mercier de répondre à
une question sur ce plateau donc trois
parcours aujourd'hui déposer un seul
autorisé comment est-ce que vous
réagissez cette information il ne semble
pas qu'il qu'un seul autorisé il me
semble que celui de madame qu'ici aussi
il est autorisé en ait trois parcours il
ya celui de aurélie et francine qui
justement prennent le relais ce samedi
parce que personnellement je dois aller
havre à rennes on l'appelle régionale
madame thyssen a déposé un mais il me
semble que la troisième équipe à déposer
effectivement le parcours qui a été
interdite malheureusement encore une
fois commencent à la suite je pense que
la question doit se poser directement en
haut lieu
parce que c'est eux qui décident
effectivement le mouvement des rides et
gilet jaune vie quand même une certaine
répression d'état
chez a précisé
le choix des mots est important
répression d'état parce qu'en
l'occurrence les interdictions ne sont
pas
concernant le moment d gilet jaune ne
concerne pas uniquement paris toutes les
villes de france sont concernés
vous avez certaines villes ou lorsqu'une
manifestation gilet jaune est organisé
comme par exemple rennes aujourd'hui il
y à une interdiction de rassemblement au
centre ville café s'explique selon vous
selon vous je pense que ça fait peur à
monsieur macron ça doit véritablement
l'embêter qu'il existe encore des gilet
jaune
alors oui tout est fait pour pour nous
rendre invisible en nous et en nous et
en nous excentrant complètement du
centre-ville de toutes les villes de
france
ça ne concerne pas malheureusement que
paris ça concerne toutes les villes de
france ça concerne mouvement des gilet
jaune alors que le mouvement en lui même
est quand même un mouvement du peuple
pour le peuple
moi ça me fait bien rire parce qu'il
donne c'est une répression une
discrimination qui vise le mouvement
mais à la base ce sont des citoyens qui
se retrouve dans toutes les autres
manifestations qu'elles soient syndicale
qu'elle soit en soutien avec les pieds
qu'importe les corps de métiers n'est ce
pas le dispositif de sécurité des
cortèges syndicaux et qui fait que les
gilet jaune voient leurs manifestations
un autorisé puisqu'il n'a pas de
dispositif de sécurité qui encadre les
manifestations des jeunes
écoutez site une des raisons pour
laquelle moi pas seulement j'ai essuyé
aussi des arrêtés d'interdiction par
rapport à certaines rues etc
lorsqu'on ont négocié des parcours enfin
on négocie des rues à chaque fois
jusqu'à obtention d'un parcours de notre
propre choix qu'on impose
c'est toujours un jeu d'échec on va dire
c'est sûr que c'est ce qu'on m'a suggéré
comme excuse que soit disant on avait
pas de service d'ordre mais lorsque j'ai
dit écoutez je suis prête à mettre un
service d'ordre s'il le faut
laissez-nous aux tournées sur les champs
par exemple à balard mâcon du net recto
verso en disant non vous savez il ya eu
16 mars il ya eu le 21 septembre même de
la casse qui s'est passé dans d'autres
manifestations hors gilet jaune
on impute aux mouvements des gilet jaune
donc service d'ordre ou pas ce sont des
fausses excuses
moi je vais vous dire la véritable
excuses c'est quoi ces politiques
point final qu'attendez vous de cet acte
66 et qu'espérez vous des semaines à
venir
très sincèrement là que ça 66 et surtout
le rassemblement continuer à
sensibiliser l'ensemble de la population
quant à ces dérives gouvernementales par
rapport à leurs décisions on a bien
compris qu'il ne reculera pas
face à cette réforme que ce soit cette
réforme comme toutes les autres qui sont
trop la réforme des retraites la réforme
des retraites effectivement cela
s'appelle une convergence avec la lutte
contre cette réforme des retraites on
sait qu'il ya un lundi noir dans les
transports parisiens lundi à l'appel de
l'unsa ratp il va y avoir également deux
jours de mobilisation jeudi prochain et
les jeunes seront présents lors de ces
manifestations
bâle et j'y joue dans la base sont des
citoyens donc ils sont partout comporte
pas le gilet le gilet on est citoyen
nous sommes tous concernés par ce qui se
passe alors le gouvernement
c'est une fixette sur le mot gilet jaune
mais à la base on est tous citoyens
travailleurs retraités fonctionnaires
syndiqués des du corps enseignant le
corps hospitalier on est tous et toutes
impacté par toutes ces décisions alors
oui vous trouverez décidé gilet jaune ne
samedi mais ces belles gilet jaune vous
les trouverez aussi dans les
manifestations en semaine parce que
c'est aussi des manifestations qui les
concernent
que ce soit par rapport avec leur leur
quotidien ou en rapport avec leur
profession donc le citoyen est partout
puisque c'est effectivement toute la
population qui est impactée par leur
décision et on sait très bien qu'ils
refuseront absolument devant rien donc
je reviens sur votre question initiale
qui était effectivement ce qu'on attend
de cette 66ème actes le rassemblement
tout simplement prochainement la semaine
prochaine ya un grand appel national du
btp les ouvriers et artisans de france
qui font appel à toutes btp afin de se
mobiliser sur le sol national
les gilets jaunes ont rejoint cet appel
nous travaillons en collaboration cette
ville se sont engagés à faire écho à
cette à cet appel la dont paris ainsi
que rejoindre l'appel national à lille
il ya aussi une prochaine grosse date
qui arrive le 14 mars où tous les corps
de métiers ainsi que le climat tout le
monde toute la france à paris dernière
question rapidement david libeskind
cofondateur du collectif chrome noir et
gilet jaune a écrit au préfet de police
de paris didier lallement pour appeler
au dialogue est ce que il ya eu des
avancées sur ce point on a vu ces
dernières semaines des figures du
mouvement des gilet jaune tels que
jérôme rodriguez ou eric roux être
contrôlé alors d'un côté évidemment il
ya le périmètre interdit de l'autre côté
peut-être un excès de zèle de la part d
des forces de l'ordre commencent qui
vous interprétez toute cette logique là
écoutez moi personnellement je juge pas
à chacun chacun oeuvre à sa façon afin
de dénoncer cette discrimination là
dessus et on choisit effectivement
d'aller au défi que je salue
complètement ensuite malheureusement je
ne peux pas répondre à la place de david
libinski c'est leur choix de d'agir de
la sorte nous nous concernant nous avons
amassé énormément de preuves par le
biais des échanges avec la préfecture
par mail etc afin de montrer
qu'effectivement il est compliqué de
déclarer un parcours selon le souhait
compte tenu des restrictions et des
interdictions et cetera et cetera
mais on a fait le choix de transmettre
toutes ses billes aux organismes
concernés pour défendre les droits
citoyens
quand vous dites c'est leur choix est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il ya une division
sera même des jeunes non il n'ya pas une
division vous savez dans le mouvement
des gilet jaune chacun est libre il n'y
a pas de chef n'y a pas de leader n'a
pas de représentant a pas de porte
parole après chacun oeuvre à sa façon
afin de dénoncer ou d'apporter sa pierre
à l'édifice comme bon selon selon son
choix
tout simplement c'est le mot de la fin
merci mme bigot d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
gilet jaune et organisatrice de
manifestations